hello everyone and welcome to this
session
on python projects and today we're going
to discuss about how to send emails
using python
so we will see the piece of code in our
jupyter notebook that how can we
leverage python as a programming
language to connect
with smtp server email servers
and send emails
to the desired recipient simple emails
emails with attachment etc so we will
see with certain examples
before we move ahead
just make sure
that whatever email id we are going to
use
for
sending emails so we are going to use
our gmail
so make sure in your gmail you have
allowed
less secure app access and that's
after this
if you have enabled this after that only
you will be able to send email using
python so please make sure that you have
enabled this less secure app access
okay
so we are going to use our gmail account
as an example so that's why we are doing
this now let's
start
so first of all you have to import
the relevant python library which is the
smtp lib and ssl library
okay
and then
you need to mention
the sender email
and the password
of your email id
then provide the details of the
receivers whom all you want to send the
email okay
then
we will
enter the details of the email body
the data which we want to send in an
email to the receiver
now coming to connectivity with the
email server now at this point we are
utilizing this utility ssl to create a
context
and after this we will make connection
with the gmail server and by default the
ssl gmail server
is running on port 465
then we will login
and then
send an email
okay so we need to connect to the
gmail's smtp outgoing mail server
then we need to provide the login
information and then send email so now
when i will execute this point
now i will try to check
my inbox and if you can see
there is an email which i have received
just now
that and which has
this is the content this email is sent
using python and subject is mail from
simply learn so this is the
very simple
piece of code which allows you to send
email from your
python code now let's take a look at
another example
where we will try to send email in an
html
body right
okay so similarly we will start by
importing smtp and ssl
but also we will add two new libraries
which is
mind text and multipart now because
we are trying to send
a email in a html body part
so
i'm going to provide the email addresses
of the sender and the receiver so i'm
going to send email to myself
i'll take my password as an input
now
i have to
provide
the multi mind multi part which i'm
going to provide as alternative
subject as anything which you can put
multi-part test
sender email in the receiver email
now i am creating a text and an html
body part
so this is an html body which will go in
my email
now i am creating two variables
one in which i am defining my text part
which is text plain and another part i
am adding my html which is i am tagging
as
html now you attach both part one
and part two
in the message
okay so now your message has both text
and the html
now thereafter
you have to create the same connectivity
with your smtp gmail
login
and then
you have provided the details of the
sender and the receiver now you have to
apply message dot as underscore string
so now this is the this is the
difference from a previous example
where now you have encapsulated the html
in the text part encapsulated in a
message and then you are converting into
a string and
sending
now now i have received an email
multi-part test
if you see this is an html body
where i have kept this as a header and
this as a plain text we are sending
email using
python so if you see this has come in
bold as a header and this has come as a
plain text
okay
now another important aspect any email
generally you also need flexibility to
add an attachment to it
okay so right now what we have done is
we have just
created the email body in a different
style
earlier we had a plain text
now here we
created the body in html
now we want to attachment
so what we will do is we will say import
email smtp live ssl
now
you have to import packages of encoders
mime base
my multipart and mime text
now my other variables
an email with attachment from python
this is my subject
this is an email with attachment sent
from python this is the body
sender and receivable
email and password
now i'll put all these variables
encapsulate in a message which is my
multipart
okay the from details the two details
subject and the receiver email
now i'm gonna attach the body
and now i'm going to define the name of
the file which i want to attach
now make sure
like i'm running this python script from
my
folder
c drive
users query j
and in this folder i have a document
called document.pdf which i have kept it
already so you make sure that the
document is lying in the same folder
from where you're running the script
and then
you have to
open the file
attach the file to the payload in octet
stream
then you need to encode it in the base64
okay and then add header content
description
with the file attachment and the file
name this is essential
then at this part now your part is ready
you have
encapsulated the entire attachment in
the part and you attach that part to the
message
convert the message as string
now you are at the point of creating
connection with the smtp server
sender email receiver email and the text
part
and you need to send it
now if you go to an email this is the
document
pdf which has come as an attachment and
you received it
so we have seen three variations of how
you can send email from python
one
same plain simple vanilla email with
simple text
second you are sending email with html
body where you can use the html tags
third sending email with attachment
the common part between all the three
parts is that you need to create a
connectivity with the smtp server
okay
and uh provide your credentials of the
sender email
and the data which you want to send in
the attachment
in other two cases where you were
sending html body we used mime text and
mind multipart and in the attachment
part we use mime base as an extra
library which we are supposed to use in
order to send an attachment
okay
so i hope you guys had a great learning
session and you will be able to apply
these concepts in your day-to-day python
programming thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here